yeah you delay to talk about this
trailer I have to talk about the follow
up trailer - what is it statistically
the most hated trailer on YouTube that's
what the first Ghostbuster trailer is
this actually isn't the second trailer
though is listed as the second trailer
there was actually the trailer everyone
hated then they tweaked and revamped
that trailer a bit and then re-released
it as the first trailer but it's like
here's our actual vision for the first
trailer please don't hate us and now you
have this trailer which is the second
trailer which is ultimately as funny
it's just more of what we already knew
I'll give the trailer props for that
ultimately all we know for certain is
that these four people come together and
they bust ghosts and there are a lot of
references in this trailer to the last
movie now should they meet with the
mayor and they're like we don't want
mass hysteria go back to the first movie
you see this big thing that looks like
Stay Puft crashing through the city
although it doesn't actually look like
Stay Puft it actually looks like the
Ghostbusters logo so instead of Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man there's a big
Ghostbusters logo I think point is a big
white puff that's crushing the city hey
benefit of the doubt maybe they're like
we don't want to ruin the movie with
their twists and turns in this movie
we'll show you vagaries throughout the
trailer which is more or less what I
always ask trailers to do so hate
problems and this trailer having a lot
of throwback to the original there's
that part of your brain is like all
right it's kind of unoriginal to do that
why wouldn't I just watch my
Ghostbusters movie that I already have
but yes the force awakens did do that
you got to address that force
awakens had a lot of plot points in it
that were in the original Star Wars
movie and although I still say the force
awakens was great it it is a glaring
thing you do have to address that if you
say it's not there you're just blind but
the force awakens did something that
this Ghostbusters trailer campaign is
not doing and that is they saved it for
the movie if the trailers for the force
awakens showed that they had echoing
plot points from the first Star Wars
movie people would have backed up me
like hey with what white hood deja vu
why are you doing that that's stupid so
you've got a snare people with intrigue
and then when they're in the theater
kind of dropped the ball that they're
gonna see some similarities but
hopefully the movie is good enough to
where they just kind of look past it as
they're going through they're like I
didn't want you know that's cool though
it's almost like I feel bad for this
Ghostbusters movie at this point because
it's kind of dead on arrival a valuable
lesson to learn before you start making
movies and cutting together trailers or
even meeting human beings is that
there's no second first impression the
first impression for this movie was the
first trailer everyone Hey
now everyone's gonna hate the
Ghostbusters period the new Ghostbusters
that is and the weird thing is I've seen
this weird-ass stigma out there words
like will you hate this Ghostbusters
trailer or the movie coming out you've
got to be a sexist that's not a sex
thing the first trailer just didn't look
that good granted this trailer looks
better than the first one but you can't
help but have that impression that that
first trailer left in your head while
you watch this trailer in the end
they're still remaking ghostbusters you
imagine what would happen if they remade
Rock T 1 or Star Wars at least rocky
they have the grace to be like yeah yeah
Creed it's a continuation it's kind of a
reboot but it's still in the same
chronological storyline funny thing is
when Leslie Jones looks like she tries
the mosh pit and no one grabs her and
she smacks the ground she's like I don't
know if that was a race thing or a levee
thing but I'm mad as hell lady thing I
don't think so race thing you tell me
movie you're the one who has a black
chick working a subway I'm alright I
usually don't throughout the race card I
really don't but it is interesting
you're remaking ghostbusters and so you
make them all women because the area
progressive times in 2016 but let's not
give the black chick a PhD let's not go
nuts there yeah put her in the subway
she's fine how do you think the
conversation for that one down was it
all like alright sir we're remaking
ghostbusters what do you think fantastic
ideas Nathan we make them all women in
2016 this is a very progressive dime you
know track well with the audience out
there yeah and speaking of progressive
this is a great opportunity to have the
black person have a degree not just be
the street smart one I think we can make
them a scientist this time if I'm
assessing the characters like I said she
looks like she has don't give a
attitude she's the one who's like wow
you're so smart she winks and smiles
like yeah I know why not have her be the
stray smart one with the attitude I'm
just saying if you want to make a
progressive ghostbusters don't stop at
the sex change
I mean they're obviously not above
changing it up there trying to make
Chris Hemsworth look like a dork in this
movie that dude is Thor guys in the end
this new Ghostbusters trailer was a lot
better than the first trailer we got but
no one's gonna really give it a shot now
there's no second first impression but I
do genuinely think when I reflect like
when I think about an alternate reality
or something where they remake
Ghostbusters with an all-male cast I
think it would be getting comparable
hate it's just the fact that they're
remaking Ghostbusters and it doesn't
really look that great not mind-blowing
Lee great but hey like I said the
trailers are really vague they're just
showing us echos of the first movie
maybe they're keeping it a secret I
might walk out of this movie be like
holy that was so good I need to
talk about it right now we won't know
until you see it but I want to hear what
you have to say about it so the new
Ghostbusters trailer or what is it now
Ghostbusters answer the call I guess it
has a subtitle now but not really
whatever whatever you think about this
trailer comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more